okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are continuing our
discussion of the difficult but very
important topic of multi-computation
and this is about
uh
computation where there is not one
thread of evaluation one thread of time
and there are many different
applications for this
and
we are trying to understand how to make
general
um
a general framework for dealing with
these kinds of things
so i'd like to remember where we had
gotten to last time
we were talking about
uh
okay so nick had been showing
multi-replace
but i think what we
what we realize
is that
what is this
gosh
um
well there are lots of good things here
all right let's let's see how we're
focusing this
um
we want to
talk about
hold on here just put this in the right
place
um
okay oops
typo ah i can't leave that
there um
sorry i am
this is
okay
all right
let's see can can
we remember where we had gotten to last
time
we were talking here about
uh
maybe
we're talking about unification
and we were talking about uh
we're talking about this concept
oh okay
the the general issue is
you have
a
we've been talking about you have an
expression
given an expression
there are multiple transformations that
to do
and that can be done
on it
and we can represent those by pattern
matching and multi-replace as an example
of how to do that is that is that right
is that the is that what we're claiming
here
right that's right um
and and in what sense is multi-replace
the general case what does multi replace
i mean
you you have to specify
what are you specifying when you do a
replacement in a in
in a replacement
you have to say
where it is happening
uh how variables are bound
and what rule is being used
is that a fair assessment so for example
if i say something like um
uh
i don't know
f of abc
and i'm using the rule
um
f of x double blank y blank goes to
whatever
um
oops i used that rule
um
then what i'm going to need to know
is well actually let's say i do
something like um g of
that comma f of x y etc cetera this goes
to
you know x x of x blank x y
okay
okay so what i'm going to need to know
that is incredibly terrifying that x
what on earth happened there this oh my
gosh
that would just be
um okay but any case when that
transformation happens how would i find
out where the transformation happened
and i think is it the case that next
multi-replace gives me that information
where is the multi-replace code by the
way
oh it's already in the repository you
can use resource function
so wait so is the replacement though
i mean how do you specify where it
replaced you can't just do a single
position specification because it might
there might be further choices exactly
if you know what i mean
yes so we can neither get that
information out nor can we put that
information here
that's part of where
you know
that's part of something we've never
needed
but we're going to need it now
well maybe it's some something about you
know
you you can return some association
where like for each
pattern
you know where you made a choice you
have the pattern as a key and that is
the value you have the position that
that pattern was bound to or something
nick how do i use multi-replace oops i
definitely don't want that
okay so
this is so what next thing is doing here
is it's saying
what is it saying it's saying that's the
position at which this transformation is
happening
but now it's not giving me additional
binding information but does it have a
way to do that
no not directly well there is a way to
pass it on but not
extract it right now
okay
it's not just about knowing what x was
bound you know x underscores bound to
because it's also like
there might be
you know
maybe maybe you know list one is the
position of the outermost sort of thing
that was replaced but there may have
been further choices
you know there might be multiple
replacements that you can do
right like orderlessness for example
could be a
there are multiple yeah it's a replace
list that's why you have
values in lists
because there can be multiple
even at the single position
there might be multiple results
okay so i mean in this case here
if i were to do just this for example
then that would be something that would
be eligible for replace list
well maybe not that because it's
it's only one
okay
but the difficulty here is that we're
not tracking
okay so i mean one issue then
is tracking the information
you know
issue number one
tracking information on transformations
and and that's what we need to be able
to do all the fancy stuff that we've
done with multi-way systems like branch
shield graphs and causal graphs and
things i think is that we need to have
that kind of tracking information is
that true or is that
yeah because because we need to know
right now all we know is we got this
expression out we do not know the
lineage by which that expression was
generated
and that's what we need to know i
believe
right for the puzzle graph especially
right
but
but so
again i want to i want to kind of
reiterate
you know we've got
different objectives here we've got
uh things like find replace path
which i gather and roger maybe you can
speak to this i saw
some indication that that uh charles and
the graftery people were thinking about
infinite graphs with generators
is that right
um
not i mean
that came up from giulio because of beam
search
okay
um so not not specifically but very big
ones i mean
like
okay but i mean so so graphs generated
by algorithms
out of core
maybe that's a different story than out
of core graphs maybe not maybe it's a
similar story because if you have an out
of core graph
you're
sort of fine
you sort of can't look at the whole
thing at once type of thing so right so
you have to have an algorithm for
deciding what to do next which is
similar to the an algorithm for deciding
what part piece of graph to build next
so to speak
yeah but big and outer core
is decidable algorithmic stuff is not
you know it can be infinite so i think
you get it's rife with undecidability
and stuff well it is but but
even the out of core case if you've got
a petabyte-sized graph
that's how finite
i know i know i know but this is one of
these theoretical things i mean if you
if you go and get lost
in the wrong corner of the petabyte yeah
you might likely never get found not
good yeah don't do that
right so
okay so i mean what we've got here
with um
uh
okay
i mean
we've got this find replace path
again
is
you know one thing is
we just wanted to kind of say something
here that you may or may not be aware of
um
we have many sort of
algorithmic rewrite systems even though
they're not presented as such
classically
like gaussian elimination is a rewrite
system
and
you know when you do row reduce you do
actually implicitly or when you do lu
decomposition you do implicitly know in
what order things happened
okay i'm saying it's all reconstructable
same thing for grebner basis
you know um
that's interesting so i mean when you do
polynomial reduce you actually
know exactly what that's what it tells
you what that reduction is okay so
computation tracing your point is that
things like uh you know row reduce
global basis
and lu decomposition
you know and so on
they they give you
a you know the path
really how does how does
okay row reduce for example how does it
give you i thought it only gave you the
final reduction no row reduce does only
give you the final reduction you need to
use lu decomposition if you want the
whole thing
maybe i'm going to learn what led
composition does after all these years
okay what does it actually give you
well first of all it uses a like like
let's say that you figured out the
permutation order so you're going to
reorder your equations
and it gives you a lower triangular and
upper triangular matrix packed into one
which is something that we are going to
revisit the packaging for
this is very efficient but so the lower
triangular matrix
uh
uh you know it gives you the factors
that matrix
into a lower triangular upper triangular
matrix
and so
with when if you're going to reduce
if you're going to solve later on
you saw first that lower triang
you know lower triangular times a vector
equals something
and that you can solve with forward
substitution that gives you the path
then you do a next step which is the
upper triangle equals you know that
vector okay the path is there but the
path is pretty encrypted yes exactly
okay because most you know i mean the
question is do you need it what do you
need it for type things
right i mean another case of this
obviously and also by the way you know
so so when we compute grobner basis we
don't get the transformation
from the original set to
uh the basis
but sometimes you actually need that
transformation just like row reduce just
give the final result or grab the bases
just give the final result
and
and sometimes you need that you know
that that transformation so we you know
it's something for the future which we
do
so we've got a version of this which is
the proof function of find equational
proof
that is one of these things it's not
particularly useful because all you can
really do with it is you know take off
the the hold and just evaluate it
right so it isn't really it is in
principle it is a path but it is not a
very usefully presented path i mean the
only useful path that i'm aware of is
the find path function you know your
path
because where where what you're dealing
with is there a graph rather than
computation steps do you mean find
shortest path or what path
i think we have a fine path function
which we do have we do have fine paths
it's very general right that's okay we
can say shine find shortest path doesn't
really matter but but my point is that
there
you know the nodes in a graph
and this is where optimization comes in
a lot of times a lot of these functions
have many solutions
you know like that's what we're
encountering up there now there are many
ways okay
is there a best one
you know so you don't you know because
some of these that's one that's one case
that's that's the non-multi-computation
way to think about this is there a best
one the whole point of this
multi-computation idea is there are many
other things you can look at other than
just the best one
yeah so you want other filters probably
yes but you probably don't want all of
them because that's like not practical
no you don't want all of them that's the
whole point you don't want all of them
you want that is the point of this
observer theory thing that we're trying
to build is what kinds of things could
you want
yes you might want you know the
probability density you might want
across a space you might want the best
one you might want various other things
but i think this is a relevant point the
nodes in a graph are much better defined
than the stages in a computation
that is and that's you know when you can
represent a computation as a graph
then it's very easy to say we got to
this stage in the computation but when
the computation is something
more like you know a stage in
transformation rules it's much less
obvious what you got to
if that makes sense
and
you know i suppose in
in yeah i mean really the question is
can the computation
be represented by a well-defined state
okay so for example
um
eg a string multi-way system absolutely
can be
a string multi-way system it's just the
state is just a string
but in the general case
well okay the the
okay be represented by general case it
might be a whole stack
yeah that's what i'm thinking i think
yes it can because it's actually doing
it
you know and they're called different
things they called a stack a
continuation or for lazy ml a graph
which has a graph rewrite system to do
it
right but i mean so but that that's also
related to
this fact you don't actually know which
computation was done the state
you know a
state
is just the static information on the
result of the computation
no it's like when you do a recursion
where you're at in the middle type thing
yeah
right i mean it's it's like knowing the
list of states doesn't doesn't
necessarily tell you the the list of of
choices that were made that's correct
it doesn't the state is static
information on the results of the
computation
but not its provenance
now
in the usual true
thing in the in the usual case
usually the state is all you need to go
forward
i believe that's right
that that's kind of the you know you
know
that that's sort of the definition of
state actually
you know if it's if that's not the case
then and it's not a state
fair enough
fair enough
i mean in other words
so
we are denying the possibility
that it could be history dependent that
it's this
yeah your point is if if it is history
dependent the state better contain a
record of the history yes
okay
but now
for
our
see for the observer
okay
but the observer may care about more
than just the state
e.g the causal graph et cetera et cetera
et cetera
so i'm getting so confused here because
there is a notion of observer like in
control systems and its job is to
get the state
oh gosh
that's you know that's what coleman did
in the 60s that's what an observer is
um explain
so
if you have a system
physical system you may not be able to
measure everything about that physical
system
for practical reasons
etc
and
can you infer the state from the things
that you can measure
and
um
yeah state of yes that sounds right
james boyd
and
and what's used in practice is what's
called
actually an asymptotic observer which is
one that converges to the true state
you know it basically simulates the
system in parallel and then
looks at sort of how wrong is it so it
can converge into the true state
it converges very fast it's mostly
that's what a comma filter is
it's an observer
right but a common filter what is its
internal representation what is its
internal information
it's it's a it's a it's a system of uh
constant coefficient differential
equations
so you're effectively fitting those to
the observed data
yes
and that is
yeah you have feedback that causes it
converge to the true state that you're
trying to observe
okay so this is state observers which is
a little different than what we're
talking about because we're talking
about
versus
essentially
multi-way observers
okay because what you're talking about
is
you have a given
you believe okay so
look but the state that it's here it
summarizes the history there is no more
if you see what i'm saying no i
understand that but but
what i'm saying is
in in one of our multi-way graphs let's
say something like this every one of
those nodes is a state
and
the whole point of this
multi-computation idea is that you allow
the possibility that there are many
states many threads of time
you don't say there is a particular
state we just don't know it completely
you say there are actually many states
running sort of in parallel in time
which is i think a different way of
thinking about things and what what
you're saying here is in control systems
there is a definite state of the world
imagine you imagine there is a definite
state of the world
um
but you don't know it
but you know but you know only
uh shadows of it
exactly
and it's super i mean this this this
notion of observer just you know it's
immensely practical
i mean
it means that you can ship systems
without too many sensors or you don't
need sensors in hostile environments
where you can't have them and things
like that but you can still infer
where the system is what's going on
can you deduce
enough about the system
uh
given a given a model so
so for us i mean things like learn
distribution
and um
i mean what are the analogous things
we've got um
uh
uh
what what's the modern machine learning
version of this the modern machine
learning version would be essentially a
net train wouldn't it
or is that not no i mean this goes on
um
it's a thing that learns all the time
i'm saying that there's feedback so it
sort of converges it it learns
okay so what you said enforcement
learning or something
yeah it's closer to that
i mean roger has certainly made the
claim that reinforcement learning is
just control feedback control
well
optimal control
you know they're they're too yes
okay so what this is doing
this is making something which given
what the heck is this doing
so give us some go go ahead this says
um
uh
can i think of it as inside its brain
are a bunch of odes whose coefficients
are getting tweaked based on the data
it's seeing
and
if you want to know other things about
the system
you can disconnect the you can just ask
the brain
kind of to run its odes and see what it
produces is that the right kind of model
i mean it's like open up the notes
um
it's just i can't connect to what you're
saying
um
so
oh [ __ ] we need to update this this is
the old style i'm sorry this is not
going to help us
then uh
okay but in any case
let's just
i i think this is not as relevant as it
might be to this other than that the
words are the same
because
what you're saying here
is that
think about sort of physically how it's
connected okay it's it's reading the
inputs that goes to your system whatever
that is your car or a robot
you know your control inputs the things
that you can actually observe it doesn't
read the things that you cannot observe
like the wind blowing on the car
those are called that's treated as noise
it reads the output
what the card actually does how it moves
or how the robot arm moves
but it doesn't say but it also has a
model that maybe you don't actually
measure the output perfectly so there's
a measurement noise so those the two two
kinds of noises that are going on
right i mean this is awfully like
reinforcement learning
yeah and then
given those two streams of data and they
don't stop you know there's not a
function there's streams infinite
streams of data
can i
get a good estimate of what the internal
state is of the system
well internal state requires a model i
mean in our in our case wouldn't it
simply be in the multi-computational
case that is the observer tries to
determine if they have an accurate
description of their foliation
right as opposed to some
some single internal
because it's state
be
yes yes but that's a much more
complicated issue i mean that's not what
this is
this is why multi-computation is a
different story yeah exactly
i mean
this is a question of
you don't know
there may be many branches you don't
really care about the relationship
between the branches you are merely
trying to nail
the characteristics of your branch as
well as you can and you believe you're
on a particular branch
whereas the whole idea of this
multi-computation thing is there are
many branches that you can consider
and the observer is capable of
aggregating multiple branches together
i mean the observer is essentially core
screening across many branches
yeah but i mean it's typically it's
continuous right so it's not a discrete
model like you're doing but yes i think
what you're saying is roughly correct
right and the continuous limit of
multi-way systems is not well understood
we do not know what it is
i see it is likely a very complicated
thing it is quite possibly in the case
of string string rewriting systems it is
quite likely that the continuum limit is
a string field theory where string is
used in a different sense
just to give a sense of how complicated
it is
um
so okay
so what we've got here
i
mean
okay we're still coming back to
uh
okay we've got the state of the system
that in our model of computation is
represented by a symbolic expression
right so
a state of the system in our world
equals a symbolic expression basically
that's that's what we're saying is going
on now you could have it you could say
oh it's real numbers it's a function
whatever else but we're saying the state
of the system is a symbolic expression
what we do not have a representation of
is the lineage of that symbolic
expression that's the thing that we need
in the case of a proof
same thing we need in these paths and so
on what how do we represent the lineage
of a symbolic expression
knowing that okay so so the the issue of
representing lineage
um
one of the issues is
uh you know
one issue is
there is much shared lineage and we
don't want to represent it all of it
separately
does that make sense aren't you
basically thinking of this as the term
rewrite system
yes
so
don't you just want the various terms
and what rewrote it in each step
i i would say that if you have a
function applied at each step
then this is relatively easy a problem
we have in find the question approved is
when we have the critical parallels the
the unifying of patterns and things like
that it's this merging of lines that
gets difficult to express and we don't
have a way of expressing it in in the
proof function
critical pair are called s polynomials
in the case of gravina bases
and we don't we don't output
the mapping
you know it's kind of like row reduced
doesn't output sort of the
transformation matrix how you got there
mm-hmm
and this okay
it's the same yeah so nick has this nice
way of thinking about this in terms of
what we're calling by substitution
which is a
sort of cleaner version of
uh i mean it has to do with okay so i
think we had examples here of
substitution
where you're going
where it is
doing a traditional pattern match
versus co-substitution
where it is using the fact that it is
matching into a pattern
and the pattern is being specialized
to follow this form
that makes sense so the pattern is
specialized by having x blank
be specialized to be
and then this pattern can be applied
does that make sense to people
and that appears to be a necessary piece
of
sort of the general term rewriting
concept
i mean it's worth remembering
that things like
well we actually don't know to what
extent maybe we do know and i don't know
it to what extent you can do term
rewriting without by substitution and
still eventually get to the same result
i think we have examples where you
definitely cannot get to the same result
you get stuck
pure substitution doesn't get you to the
end
but jose i think this is the this is
what's happening in a critical pair
lemma is a transformation that is not
one of our traditional
it is a by-substitution
as opposed or a co-substitution as
opposed to a substitution so
substitution is there is a pattern
and you are
you are specializing the pattern in
order to apply it to the expression in
co-substitution you are specializing the
expression
to
conform it to the pattern
actually that's a pretty good way to
explain this
does that make sense to people
i do agree that we need something like
this i i must admit i don't yet fully
understand it well i've always thought
that we need a function that we stay
below there which is kind of what you're
referring to stephen which is the
unification
solver
which basically would give you solutions
to those two you know
what's the solution to those two
matching there that you have below yes
and that can be many
right but that that comes back to this
very basic thing that we had up here we
don't have a way to output what is the
binding you know we only have an
implicit way to output what is the
binding for x and y
i mean the only way we have to output it
is to use it in the result
am i making sense we don't have we have
no although what's wrong with that i
don't know i mean and if you
yeah
and if you want to return other things
too you can use so and reap really
maybe maybe although although that gives
puts in an undifferentiated vat of stuff
it doesn't give you i mean like like for
example it was unclear what else how
else you'd have it but yeah okay well
that's the question i mean that's the
question how do we represent tracing of
computations
that is that continues to be the
question i mean back in 1990 we tried to
solve this with the trace function which
was not very successful
um it's incomprehensible actually i mean
i don't really know whether we've looked
at um
uh
i mean isn't there couldn't that perfect
turn rewrite system be kind of like a
debugger do step by step
no because it's multi-way
see that's the problem the problem is
but but we implement something right
if you want to implement something no no
we implement something but the whole
point of this multi-computation idea oh
to explore everything is to explore
everything
right that's that's the whole
yeah
that's that's what's complicated
right so yes i mean the thing we've done
we have managed to slice through this
this horrendous complexity by just doing
the take the first pattern matching
result and use it right that's how our
evaluator has worked forever
right what we're saying now is go beyond
that and consider all possible
evaluation paths
and and then the concept of this
observer
thing is given all possible evaluation
paths what do you look for from that
whole collection of possible paths
one thing would be the path which does
the best another thing would be the
highest density of paths another thing
would be something else
does that make sense roger
yeah but i'm just thinking of
i understand the research question
have you thought about the
sort of
why you want to do that
you know in a production i mean in a
well okay okay so so
for example
i mean there are
okay
this is like an ensemble i mean you are
basically doing the time history of an
ensemble
okay
mostly in physics people punt on that
they use the canonical ensemble which is
time independent right and they just say
on average each branch will be weighted
with either minus beta h or whatever
okay
just so you know you may not remember
this but when we did random processes
we have a way to observe the ensemble we
have a thing called slice distribution
will give a temporal slice of the full
ensemble
you mean
that is very interesting i had no idea
it's very general what is an ensemble
and it it can give a multi-slice even
an ensemble just means a collection of
states so for example a typical thing
would be in a spin system like so if you
go to you know to get a very concrete
thing here let me let me just answer the
question of what an ensemble is and then
we'll come back to that i mean that it's
just it's just the configuration of all
possible states
make sense
yeah but to get a very concrete
practical visual thing go to random
function
okay
scroll down a little bit
this is a function that that doesn't
yeah but there should be something
better
sorry
no no nothing nothing what did you say
because with the function i just said
this is a function is very i mean you
might expect random function is going to
return you you know yeah
or something
yeah
go for neat then i just like we should
have this where you can see that we
usually plot the whole ensemble too but
apparently we don't for the
just simulate one here because the
random function is set up to give you a
whole ensemble
okay yeah or neat example should be
probably many more let's see
i hope yeah i forget it but the ensemble
is when you have many of them okay so
now let me understand so infinitely many
of them and so our temporal data is the
data representation of the multi-way
of the full ensemble okay even though
i've been trying to kill temporal data
it may turn out that it's actually
exactly what we need
to tell me yeah do that for a hundred
okay crank that 10 up to 100 or
something or a thousand
okay fine there's another thing
right now if you want to do slice
distribution slice distribution on vena
process
okay that can give either can take
temporal data or it can take the actual
sort of prop mechanism so they take that
and they'll slice it at a particular
time
like one or something
but
no no i just i pressed the wrong button
okay okay don't do that
comma four okay
yeah look at that so f4 we have a
description
of
of the ensemble there and it's actually
a distribution
of values
that would be very cool if you could do
this you can yes you can
isn't that amazing that's amazing so now
we can do that for all of our random
processes
well i mean there's a limit to how far
you can go analytically but slice
distribution of a process
of one or several t's so you can do
multi slices too you get the
multivariate distribution but let's say
a single t
now that is a random variable and you
can generate random variables from it so
you can call random variable on that
slice distribution happily
i bet it's not very happy in this case
well this one has a parameter and so you
need a concrete t for that to happen
well that one auto evaluates
so so obviously yeah you know okay well
give me a more complicated process
random process uh
well you know like um
an ito process maybe or something
okay so the stationary distribution
is what you would get
that is the
that's the limit at you know for free
yeah if it is if it does have one not
all of them have one
okay
so here
just so i understand um
what's a good example of a process here
well you want something that's not too
complicated but you know that one is
pretty complicated but
can you do fractional brownian motion
uh i'm not sure i can't i don't think so
okay i might be asking too much
well it wouldn't be too far it it
wouldn't be too far off from what we
have it's probably one of the examples
down there but i don't want to
okay but this
i had no idea we could have things with
differentials like that is that a common
thing that we've done elsewhere no we've
done it for ito process and stratanovic
process
no but look at these differentials
that's a language
it's a language we define a new symbolic
language we do that a lot of times for
our solvers
you know yeah but why why don't we allow
that in differential equations for
example because we don't know what to do
with them in in differential equations
why not if dx of t i mean why is that
equal oh i'm sorry no no no we do allow
differentials there because you know the
wolfram alpha team asked for it so we do
support it for diesel so for desolve for
example i can say this
i don't know if that works but there's
some version of that that works
oh
the heck is that
well i don't think that we're using that
notation for it there but there is a
notation that allows a separate separate
thing which maybe somebody could make a
note of this is something we should look
at making that work but that's very far
away from
the the real topic here yeah
uh
okay so so i see richard just put some
interesting things in the chat let's
look at that in a minute
um okay so so what you're saying here
you you say i shouldn't use a detail
process i should do something else yeah
it's probably it's just like overcome i
mean you can do that later but just pick
something a little center what would you
like a random walk random walk well i
was wanting something which had a
stationarity in the end
okay does that one have that i don't
know no it doesn't the random walk just
gets bigger and bigger just puffs and
puffs out
and it's also got analytical solution
yeah so some of these guys have it some
of these guys are stationary some are
not okay so and we can tell
okay so but but this
this is a discrete time thing yeah so
random function of that for instance
and so there
you have to say oh over what time
interval back zero to yeah and then that
will get you one path okay so now if i
say list line plot of that
why does that only give one
because you only asked for one
you said over what time horizon but you
didn't say that you wanted more than one
instance in the random function
so if you say after zero to 100 if you
say that you want a hundred of them
you'll get a hundred of
oh i see that had a time interval there
yeah
okay
okay
fine that looks like it's becoming
stationary it looks exceptionally
stationary yes
okay
so now what you can ask for you can ask
for from that process you can ask for
stationary distribution
i think it
was happening
oh look at that
okay so i'm trying to understand what
where were we getting this from so slice
distribution
you're saying
is the distribution
of okay so the point is that the process
here a little bit of a difference to
what we're doing
the process here but i think that's what
we call a foliation or something
yes it is the slice but what you're
doing there
okay can you pick other foliations other
than the the flat foliation
you can do several t's and now you you
you get sort of you look at two spots
basically no i understand that but the
issue is what we're dealing with is okay
so
the thing that you've got that is a big
simplifying feature
is that your states
are defined by just individual numbers
like the state of the wiener process is
the value at that position there yeah i
mean like on the on the time vertical
you mean yeah no it's not on the club on
the first
on the values
the value can be vectors but yes you
know so it can be a little bit more but
basically yes
the value is numerical
yeah and i mean it can be a vector it
could be but nothing more
it can be finite like markov chains it's
sort of a finite
you know
symbolically perhaps this is an answer
to the question of what
i mean because
you know like like i've looked
at length at things like
you know nest graph
x goes
to uh
2x one plus x
okay starting with one
going five steps
okay
now how does that compare to what you're
doing here
let's say
do you get what i'm saying so that's
going
that's saying at every step
you've got these two possibilities and i
don't think you've got
in some sense at every step here you've
got an infinite number of possibilities
and the steps so sometimes you have a
discrete process where you have it in
steps
take that arma process
it's basically a difference equation
it's a linear difference equation
you know
where um you drive it with white noise
and
you you have a recurrence of the
previous values
you know and that recurrence is
implicitly stated there where it says
minus 0.3 comma 0.1 yep
it says
y of k plus 2
minus 0.3 y of k plus 1
plus 0.1 y of k equals
0.4 times u
of k which is just white noise so that's
just hold on so this is like saying
linear recurrence of
you know let's say it was minus 3 1. it
was linear recurrence it doesn't have
the right hand side see i'm saying it
can't do filtering it's not driven it's
just autonomous
which i'm saying there's no input to
this thing
it's just initial value and a recurrence
and like in control systems here there's
stuff coming in
okay that's the initial values yeah
there's stuff coming in that drives it
all the time
okay
okay but let's okay um but sorry isn't
it the case that the paths in the
statistical case are all independent
they don't interact with each other well
what you have in the graph is that there
is this sort of recombination
exactly exactly that's right that's
right that's right that's right because
the main thing that's happening here
which happens in term rewriting is this
notion of equivalence
yeah
now they they you don't think of them
you think of that there are many
possible paths but there is no notion of
them talking crosstalking or anything
like that this is the difference between
nest graph and nest tree
is there a nest
okay so let's look at what nest tree
does in this case
i think it is
yes i think it is
i had forgotten the existence of nest
tree beautiful
right a nest tree how would we get from
from the nest tree to the nest graph
well if you recognize if those states
are actual states you could kind of
recognize them and you would get a dag
well yes that's what we're getting here
as a dag but my question is i'm just
asking in terms of trees
is there a way to go from that tree to
that graph
again that will be a question for you
we don't have to try this functionality
that does that
merge three functions
what what is it is there
you're saying research
resource function
yeah
merge tree
yeah
and what do i do i just feed it a tree
yes you just feel it
wow
okay and so
is that your function nick
right yes
did you make it for some purpose that is
related to this
for
okay
how does it decide which to merge
by subtree
essentially just hashes each subtree
and then merges by hash
oh you can you can specify any function
that can you can run on each subtree
yeah this is like magnifying entire sub
trees not
not in individual nodes
yeah but why doesn't have to just do
graph
but why does it just isn't for us
it's just labels
it's just um
like have this label that show that the
multiple branches merge there
i see
but but wait this graph is similar to
but not identical to this graph here
um
maybe it is you just don't just
simple graph it
it doesn't look to be identical
perhaps i'm wrong but
it looks to be
i mean we can do graphite some offers my
guess i'm not sure it's the same number
of steps oh it is actually
i i'm predicting oh do you just try the
yeah isomorphism why there are several
fours
so
that's what i'm confused by
yeah i would expect just a single four
now this is the this is the difference
whether you merge by subtree structure
or just by the node i think if you just
want to merge by node you just make a
graph right don't have a merge 3
function
okay wait a minute wait a minute so this
is merging by subgraphs
but by
merging by subtrees
yeah
and then what you're saying is that to
merge by node merge by node name
you are saying do that how
just by writing
graph on it i think it works
ian does that work
no
because because those tree knows
it used to work and then we changed it
so that
you always get a tree graph out by using
both the data and the position because
before if you if the data was in more
than one position
then you could get a graph that's not a
tree graph
i see yeah then now you're just vertical
now there's not a yeah but i guess now
they're all
everything's unique we don't have that
flexibility so nick what are you saying
you do with this
you just vertical place and just drop
the second part
so let's just matrix
v goes to first v
oh i see and this thing here
yes
okay and then we say simple graph on
that
well i can't tell if it's the same but
it might be
percent 64.
isomorphic graphs
cool
okay i think we're beginning to
understand the relationship between
these okay but so big issue then is the
equivalencing of paths
is something not taken into account in
these stochastic processes
that
um uh
a fair statement now let's see let's
look at these comments that richard has
here
um
uh
my gosh what is this um
what on earth
okay
um
based but on the issue of evaluation
strategy i observe a reference frame
construction oh yeah sorry i wanted to
ask roger here
so
it is still the case
that
we could imagine our equivalent of a
reference frame or a foliation
by saying in your sampling here instead
of saying time for you it is natural to
slice in your slice distribution to
slice
values
at a fixed time yeah
the generic value you know
generic slice distribution
is
all values
at fixed time
yes
yeah or several times
you know so yeah it fixed time or
multiple times
okay
so
different foliation
slash reference frame
would be
uh
you know
distribution in which
[Music]
at different values
for different values you are sampling at
different times
now maybe nobody ever cares about that
um
but let's talk about this in the context
okay so these things here
could be thought of more like uh
execution graphs
for some kind of parallel computation
and
in that case this question about what
does it mean what does the simultaneity
surface mean
it's a more complicated question and
it's much less obvious that you always
want a sample that there's even a notion
of sampling everything at
a fixed time does that make sense
absolutely
but now is is there a is there an analog
of that stochastic processes
not that i know of
i mean one could certainly imagine a
relativistic stochastic process this
will be a jose kind of question
of of you know imagine a random walk i
have never thought about this around a
relativistic random walk
what is the what is the theory of the
relativistic random walk would be the
question here
um
i don't have an answer for that
immediately
i mean i you know long long ago i worked
on relativistic kinetic theory and even
that was pretty complicated for for
example
you know like the notion of the
transform maybe this has been figured
out the notion of the relativistic
transformation for temperature
which is not unrelated to this because
what you're asking for is
do you know if that was ever figured out
relativistic transformation for
temperature jose
it was a big discussion in the early
times of special relativity and there
are several theories but the consensus
on how it's treated in general is by
always going to the rest frame we always
refer to
statistical properties in the rest frame
and that avoids completely the problem
because there is a unique preferred
observer
right like the cosmic microwave
background
even though even though the universe
wasn't supposed to have a preferred
frame there is a temperature for the
cosmic microwave background in the
preferred frame of the universe
the um
okay anyway that seems to be a sideshow
but um
uh okay but coming back let's see
richard is commenting evaluation
strategy
server reference frame construction
um
rewrite tower
what is this
this is a
oh my gosh
you see that the problem is oops the um
uh so this is a particular
rewrite
language
you know i think and i probably nobody
here knows these folk the people that
we've been interacting with in france
who've been doing these things these
tracelets and so on they may have
something relevant
to all of this although i didn't really
understand how that stuff works
okay so this is this is an example but
this is exactly what we don't want that
is a word there that's what we
effectively have in our proof
that's what that's what you typically
have in a proof
um
is it's full of words
but those say they say that that's kind
of the word say the rule basically right
or some yes the words say what is being
done yeah and um
yeah right so i mean
i think this is um
uh
right
okay the well the user defines strategy
language what is the strategy for
applying rules because that is that's
one of the big big big questions
right is the the sort of the big
question is
big question
you know
which rule to apply when
right and that's where we get into our
tree traversal order
you know where we've got
that that's this thing where we're
dealing with all of these lovely things
here
right
um
you know all this stuff
um
but we need to do better we need to have
a more you know this is all just named
strategies
see what i'm saying and the question is
what's the general
what's it
you know each one of these go ahead
i don't think these are quite strategies
for rewrite rules because here you're
like just hopping around between all the
different branches
no these are rewrite rule things because
if you have
if you imagine
that the tree is a multi-way graph
that represents possible rewrites so for
example imagine that i have a nest graph
where i have
x goes to
f of x comma g of x
okay
then what this is doing
um
and let's say that starts with an x or
something that goes four steps and then
we label those
i claim
that
[Music]
this is an evaluation order story that
exactly
order is it's it's giving you an order
to visit every single one of these nodes
i should just say
really has nothing to do with starting
from the root and going down
um and that was a thought i had earlier
when you mentioned with multi-way
systems you're mostly interested in
either very large cases or
infinite cases uh-huh but for trees it's
like you have a very finite thing and
you do want to like traverse the whole
thing and get involved okay let me
understand the analogy then which i
don't understand here so the combinator
case um
let me just pull up
some combinators
um
okay so here
uh
okay
so these are combinators
and i mean confusingly that is a single
combinator tree and this is
represents
a
a possible rewrite sequence for the
combinator and what what you're doing
here is you're selecting
different parts of the tree on which to
do the rewriting
unfortunately we've got true trees
running around here so honestly we're
thinking of using the traversal order to
somehow be
the strategy for finding where in the
expression to apply the rewrite yes i
think that's correct i see
right
which is i mean and so here references
to some positions in the rewrites than
others
right but now the place where we've got
a second tree going on
is that all possible rewrite orders
are represented by this multi-way graph
so in other words here if we think of f
and g
as two rewrites this tree this tree here
is representing all possible rewrite
orders
so when we say
we are picking so so you're right it's a
different tree we're talking about
right
so wherever i probably have it here
um
on i've got this somewhere
yeah okay so here we go so this is
a particular
you know this is one rewrite order we'll
traverse the multi-way graph like that
another one we'll traverse it like this
i think i've got somewhere here i've
probably got the comparison of left most
outer most left most innermost et cetera
et cetera
um
right it's like because of the way
you're
you're doing replacements on expressions
in a given traversal order and so the
different traversal orders give you
different like paths in the multi-way
system that's correct but that's correct
reversal order question isn't really a
traversal order in the multi-way system
you're not like skipping around
willy-nilly in the multi-way system
but you also want to do that so we've
got this is very confusing i mean it's
very confusing there's two different
things going on okay so so uh two
different tree traversal
case one
one
in the expression that is the state
where do you
do the rewrite
oh boy this is confusing
that
like give an order do you look for terms
to rewrite
that's correct and this gives you
choosing an order
gives you a single path
through the multi-way system
yes okay so another case is
to
looking at the multi-way system
and growing the multi-way graph
in what order do you grow the graph
well under like two completely different
trees there's the expression tree and
then there is sort of you know the tree
where every node is an expression yes
this is the this is the exact point that
i have been confused about since 1980.
okay
okay okay let me let me describe what
the issue is again
okay
we have in our evaluator two kinds of
recursion
kind number one recursion through it
through an expression tree to decide
where to look at next
okay recursion number two is
re-evaluation recursion
do you see what i'm saying yeah
jose pointed out that
our documentation calls the first kind
iteration
the first guy is or is it the second
kind no it's the second kind isn't it
do you remember jose
so
um
iteration is doing
is evaluating the next thing in the
expression like going through the the
various arguments
and this is represented in trace in a
flat list and recursion is re-evaluating
the same thing again
and this is represented by a by a next
level of list
and what and trace in trace
isn't this also
i i thought that the thing with like
iteration like iteration and so on is
basically it was tail recursion
actually that's what i thought too
yeah right
i mean
i mean i think there's a difference
between if i say x equals x plus one
i will hit oh gosh i thought i was going
to hit the iteration limit there
um
and if i do this
right it's recursion because it's a
nested thing
right
but this has been okay
and what's it what's a minimal example
of trace that isn't just totally
ridiculous
is there a i mean if i define
let's say i define a a um
uh let's do this if i say um x plus f of
x minus one yeah sorry can you go to the
reference
page of evaluation i put the link in the
chat okay
um okay i will just a second let me just
try this trace of
f5
oh my gosh what is this
how can i visualize this what should i
what can i do with this
um
we're going to support this in
expression treat but i don't know what
we can do right now
can we can we make this into a tree
right now is this even a tree
okay basic question one of the nested
lists and so you'd see the siblings are
iteration and the descendants are
recursion
really
so f of phi equates to five plus f of
five minus one so they're siblings
yes but i don't believe you i think
that's only going to work that's the
problem that you've actually got two
recursions going on you you are talking
about in your tree the recursion in the
tree
is going to be
recursive recursion so to speak that is
f of five going to f of four
as opposed to if i made this expression
more complicated and you had to also do
recursion through the expression so to
speak
that's a different kind of recursion
which i don't think one's representing
well there okay let's look at the um
so go out to the very end of this page
great
go to the end of this page
um yes here global control of evaluation
i think i wrote this in like 1987.
um
right so tree traversal orders like a
third point to this
i think
i think this mostly represents my
state of
of uh
leads to evaluation chains in which
successive expressions are obtained by
the application of various
transformation rules
which sounds like tail recursion
yep yes
i mean i believe i have been confused
about this for more than 40 years so
just just to which to me is the kind of
state like it's a fixed sized state type
thing you know to me
which
you know the tail recursion business you
can possibly so
right i mean
okay but
but
the okay
we've got various things various issues
here in the expression that is the state
where do you do the rewrite
how do we specify that
and then in what order you grow the
graph
how do we specify that
in this case
where do you do the rewrite
we could specify that
you know
one form of specification
would be
the language of tree traversal order
and in a sense um
treat reversal order
i.e
taking the first
uh
you know the first rewrite
in the traversal order
am i making sense
that's what that's how we'd be using
rewrite or you could
apply all of the rewrites in the
specific order
well you could do no but the problem is
i think a given order you still have
multiple different things you care about
like apply the first rule you find or
apply all rules
i agree i agree i agree so are you
taking the first rewrite so eg
in the physics project
okay we have this notion of generational
states
uh
generational states are okay so
generational states are the analog
of string replace
okay so what do i mean by that if i do
string replace here and i say i've got a
b
a a b
x
a b
okay
and i say a b goes to
you know x x x or something okay notice
it did that three times
okay it is not obvious that it would do
that three times
it is using what it is doing is it is
trying to fit in okay so there i can do
that and i'll see all of those now
notice if i do this if i say string
replace
of a b
actually let me do this a a obviously
pretty confusing that string replace
returns an output that isn't an element
of string or place list
it is confusing
i agree it is confusing now look at that
yes okay so so a good example here by
the way that should probably be in the
in the um
in the possible issues section okay so
of of of string replace and string
replace list okay so does that mean that
string replace is kind of replace
repeated
it is
it is it is doing what we would call in
the physics project the generational
states i mean it's even worse than
replace repeated though because it's
it's you know like replace repeated
it's replace all it's not even replaced
yes it's yes okay so it is the analog of
replace all which also has the feature
that if i say abc here and now i say
replace all
of f of x blank blank triple blank y
triple blank
arrow
you know x y
right it's just going to do one case
what am i saying here that's not i think
using something with pattern sequence
would have maybe made it more uh
well whatever yeah no but but i guess my
point is replace all implicitly has some
traversal order
it does you're interested in that same
operation just with a different
traversal order
no but but okay this is where it's even
more confusing okay
because
one thing you might do in a multi-way
system
every edge in a multi-way system
corresponds to a single replacement
happening
okay so for example in the string
replace here those are three
replacements in the multi-way system
let me let me show you that okay so
let's take this
and let's say
down here let's let's say resource
function
and let's give that
whoops i didn't mean that rule i meant
that
rule
and let's say
four steps
okay
so that's the multi-way graph
so the multi-way graph better be doing
the same thing that string replace list
does
right at the first level it's doing all
those string replace lists
that make sense to everybody
but then it keeps going doing more
replace lists and eventually winds up in
this state
which
in this case is the same as string
replace
okay although that might not always be
in this case there was a so so let's say
i take the initial condition
to be let's say what i did here was i
say a a goes to x here
is it possible to get something with
string replace that you couldn't get by
doing sequential
rewrites no
no it's not you have to be able to it is
a sequential rewriter
okay so let's say
is that confusing let's see
all right let me let me do this case
here
okay so this is fairly obvious
but now in this particular case
string replace
is going to give
what is it going to give actually
okay who can guess which of these it's
going to give
i have a guess i'm going to guess it's
going to give that one
yes i'm right
okay
is this is this making sense to people
what's going on here
roger can you should be called string
replace all but yes
yeah um why do you say all is
right repeated it's it's you know it
does a replacement and then it does it
again it repeats it
no that's what replace all does
well i mean
both are true both are true in this case
that's what's so confusing
yeah but i would guess that if you gave
it some cyclical thing or replace
repeated would loop forever this will
not
i think you're right yes i think you're
right yes
but but but so
okay so there are multiple things here i
mean there's first of all there's
there's these different forms of
recursion and then there is tracking
what happened
like in this case here let's say you go
to xax here okay
how do we write what we would like to do
is to write a some representation
of a path we followed to get there
what would that representation be
right now it would be a string replace
part or something a series of string
replaced parts
that makes sense
i think
i think as long as the
the siblings are always in a fixed order
that you can just use a position spec
for a dag
so you just say 3-1
i think that's a not a chance type story
i i cannot believe that there's a way to
label these dags
but but what you have as nodes here are
what i would call states
you know and we would call them states
too okay
but don't you think that's but wouldn't
that be a good you know like state state
state like a sequence of states you know
and
maybe
what you did to get from one to the
other but that's the point what you did
to get from one to the other
that's the point that's specifying that
so we have a way of representing that in
multi-way systems that's not wonderful
i mean we have this notion in multi-way
systems of a state decomposition
function event decomposition function
and so on
because an event here is i rewrote that
first a a so let me show you what the
actual representation of that
um
oh what's it called evolution events
graph
there we go okay so those are the events
i see oh boy that's confusing look at
this one here okay this is a case where
there are two possible events
well that one has three pos four
possible events
the events are essentially the output of
string replace list
okay so a representation would which
would be okay
is to say you go from this state to this
event to the state to this event
now
do you ever care about sort of
more than one event resulting in the
same state
more than one event yes absolutely two
yellow boxes giving going to the same
blue box absolutely critically so like
here that's a merge that's all to do
with confluence and so on
yes you absolutely do now the other
thing is in this picture
um
one is only showing
a single state
going to multiple states okay we also
have this notion of token event graphs
where you can have multiple tokens
that
can go into an event so in these events
every event here has just one input
you know one input one output but you
don't have to have that be the case
you can have
an event that has
multiple inputs and multiple outputs
but isn't it fairly obvious
how this corresponds to expressions you
know
the the blue
the blue boxes are expressions
yes
they are yes that's right
you know and and the yellow ones are
how do you get there
you know and you guys you list both
where and what
basically look at that notation that you
have there
yes
that's correct look i mean the point is
that with the expressions
we really view the expressions as being
collections of tokens
and
those tokens the events
ingest collections of tokens
so for example for any given expression
there may be multiple
let's think about this the multiple ways
to break it into tokens
no no that no no i'm sorry that like for
a string like this the tokens are the
characters
and it's different
collections of those characters that can
be involved in the event
but
i mean so so again the problem is
how do we represent you know what's a
good way to represent that event
okay so in the case of does somebody
remember how we're doing it in multi-way
systems i think i mean what's so
confusing here if you
if if the blue boxes are themselves
trees like expressions are trees
absolutely okay then the yellow boxes
would be kind of like a sub tree
that's correct tree that's correct you
know exactly i mean
that this sort of
we need simplification
well this is
i probably got pictures here i mean this
is um
ah where is it
yes
exactly this is this is right i mean in
a in a
one of these things here
that's for combinators okay
every node here is a tree
yeah
makes sense because that that is the
analog then
yes
right and i mean this combinator thing
is a minimal version of the kind of
thing we're dealing with with
expressions
and so again to describe a single path
through the multi-way graph you can do
that by giving a strategy for which
element of the combinator you rewrite
and it's only one
which confusingly is not the same but as
ian was pointing out
it doesn't have to be only one like
replace string replace doesn't do just
one rewrite
string replace is doing all the ones
that will fit
okay so the strategy and i believe your
tree does your tree traversal order
trying to remember now tree traversal
order is simply
an ordering and so there's another
parameter you would have to give which
is how many of the elements from the
tree traversal order do you actually do
in a particular step oh gosh no it's
more complicated than that because
the things you can do together at one
step
are not possible say there was like a
first case
like select first for trees
you could specify a traversal order and
that'll affect which thing is the first
thing you get
that's correct but if you're doing a
tree map then you're not it's just a
different operation but it still has a
tree traversal order i understand but if
you say select three things
it is not self-evident that your
strategy will allow you to have three
distinct things selected
so you could step on that's implemented
now you do tree select and you can say i
want the first three and then you can
say a traversal order and it gives you
the first three that you find in that
traversal order
in some immutable sense because those
things could be overlapping
right well they're not changing in tree
select i know i know i know in some
immutable sense i'm saying but were
those things to be rewrites you would be
toast at that point
right it's all easier if there's only
one thing you're returning that you can
then rewrite because
one is always independent of everything
else in some sense right there but as
soon as you're rewriting two things
there's the problem of what if those two
things overlap
right actually note that our stream
replace doesn't have the overlaps option
i was looking at that some other string
functions too but not that one
that's really weird
so no but what could it possibly do if
it had overlaps to true what would it
possibly do
well in these five a's it's looking at
replacing the first two and the second
two three and four
and it could it could return
like
x x x x because there are four pairs of
a's in five a's
or three pairs of a's in four a's
i see so you're saying
at the first step so let's just
understand
what that okay so if we say string what
will we do we're saying string cases for
example so it has disjoint matches
basically
it it can never
yes that's correct it is is a disjoint
matching thing so if i string cases a a
how the heck do i do this i say let's
say x blank x blank
and then overlaps goes to true
okay whereas if i say overlaps goes to
false
these are good documentation examples if
nothing else
okay whereas
right and
still replaces only following the second
i understand because string replace for
the first
would reuse an a
in the replacements
which it's refusing to do
because none of our other replacement
functions can ever reuse a part in a
replacement
right but your multi-way system is
actually doing overlaps through that's
why it has four
that's correct
because it
because any given path
never steps on its own toes
but two different paths can step on each
other's toes so to speak
um
i i have another question there's a
perhaps a roger question or others okay
so
so
um
the
let's see
when we think about gpus and parallel
computations and things like this
these issues
obviously come up
of what do you do first
i mean like like in operations on a
raise
yeah
there's got to be exactly issues like
this
um yes um
so
um yes
i mean the question is how you split
problems and how much
how where was a good split so there
aren't issues so many issues like this
because it
drags down
well so you think that the things that
we have
built in
mostly deals with when they're
independent like in parallel problems i
know right
the rich is commenting for gpus that
causal dependence analysis by the causal
graph could help yeah i agree because in
this question of what
like a modern cpu does some things
pretty
pretty amazing because they
because you have these super scalar
processors right and so they download
they ingest something like 500
instructions these days
then they compute the dependence graph
and then they schedule them on separate
functional units
and then
for the most part the programming model
that we provide
we want to
imitate as if they were happening
sequentially so we want to what's called
retire them or return them in the
correct order
okay
on the fly actually
right but so here's the point i think
right now
let's say we're doing well from language
computations on a random cpu
okay the definition of awesome language
today
is that it follows one path here
okay we've probably got pictures like
this this one here this is the path that
follows in the multi-way graph
okay
but it could be the case that
that path that path might not even be
the most efficient one to implement on
your hardware
and you might not even care that it
followed that particular path
if it was the case that all you know
many paths
get led to statistically similar let's
say you're doing image decompression for
example
and yes there are multiple paths
and
you know yes the pixels a little bit
different but doesn't really make any
difference to follow a different path
i don't believe there's any technology
right now that i mean i
you know that seems like a thing
that's like using
right like what you're describing roger
is you are making sure that
the computation can be done in exactly
the order it's supposed to be done in
yeah
and and it's pretty low i mean 500 is
impressive but it's still pretty local
to saying and and they
and and to and and but they're able to
do it like on the fly and very fast
right
if we can do something one level above
that
that's
that's more global than that sort of
instruction level basically much more
right let's see richard has a few
comments here i want to look at these um
uh
let's see there's comments about um
um
decidability
uh
see
richard you want to do you want to
say something rather than the
um rather than having me be confused
here go ahead
sure um the first point was really about
sort of evaluation strategy control
via
you know a sort of reflective language
so within the system itself
and that's something that this elan
language it sort of treats these
strategies as sort of first-class
citizens and then the the second
reference i i pasted well actually i
pasted three but the second is talking
about this sort of tower of
so you can have sort of strategies on
top of strategies and so forth how do
they represent the strategy that's the
real question what do you what is the
you know in in in something like our
symbolic language
you know all we've been able to do is
the extremely lame thing
of saying we have these you know named
strategies
how do you make a language strategies
and you should provide as much
information as possible so for example
you're talking about the sort of
application position information for
each
state through time from the initial
state that's something you would want
you kind of want full information
and then something which gives you a
kind of essentially a sort of decision
function over the
sort of um so i guess it's like state
evolution function
um
so so the normal forms would you know
given the sort of future states would
return you know
as a simple example just true or false
and and so that would give you the set
of future states
um
well it's a bit more than that it's not
yeah yeah i suppose it is it's just a
set of future states uh for for a given
state right
then this yeah there you go no i mean
the challenge which i'm trying to
understand is what is a reasonable human
understandable language
that can parametrize evaluation
strategies
that's the same they give some element
they give they give some elementary
strategies and then they sort of compose
user-defined strategies out of these
elementary strategies so that's the
approach that's taken in this elan
language but i guess i mean you know in
in the same sense the sort of
mathematica is
you know higher order conditional termi
writing i mean that's the that's the
characterization of mathematica from uh
was it bruno buckburger you know you can
sort of carry that idea to the strategy
language itself
right but that's the part that i'm not
understanding is like what would be a
primitive in the strategy language
i mean like like here we've got yeah go
ahead
uh i mean they give some uh
they give some examples about uh so
here's this non-determinism is handled
with two operators uh don't care
study for don't care choose and don't
know choose i i guess they
they have this
notion of controlling the the
non-determinism so at certain points you
sort of you either choose between what
they call it don't care choose and don't
no choose i'm not really sure on the
details but presumably this sort of
uh accumulation of all those decisions
throughout your sort of history path
then that's kind of constraining the set
of
f uh you know final normal forms
and uh
in in the paper they talk about this
sort of uh
determinate uh none sorry what does it
call the determinism mode inference so
so so given
given a strategy
uh specification then you can because
they have this compiler as well so so
given a strategy you can determine what
whether it's deterministic
semi-deterministic non-deterministic and
can perform
right so all that's saying is when you
say deterministic non-deterministic
whatever you'll be saying like here's a
multi-way graph
with this particular strategy do you get
one path or do you get many that's the
decision of whether it's multi i mean
yes i i think i understand that the the
issue here and the challenge my 40-year
challenge here is to make a language
which is actually comprehensible and
useful that can parametrize these
strategies and the part of this that is
now tantalizing is because of the
relationship between this and reference
frames in physics
you know in physics we have all kinds of
you know inertial frames and boosted
frames and accelerating frames and
things like that and those are
essentially evaluation orders you know
they're they're representations of some
kind of evaluation order thing we've got
so we've got these different cases we've
got you know depth first breadth first
we've got left most outermost et cetera
these are a whole collection of named
you know evaluation strategies
the question is what is
a i mean you you could as well say
let's just do all our computations by
naming the three kinds of things you
know plus times divide whatever those
are the only computations you want to do
but the neat thing about touring
machines was the idea that you could
essentially parameterize any computation
and of course touring machines as such
were a lousy parametrization and then we
had to you know wait for higher level
languages to have reasonable
parametrizations even lambda lambda
calculus would be better but but so my
question is what is the reasonable
parametrization of a high level
description of evaluation strategies
because it's a higher order problem than
describing a computation i think in
other words instead of describing you
rewrite this to that
you're saying of all possible rewrites
which ones do you choose to do which i i
don't know i'm somebody
i think the order is also important as
well so
yeah it's not just it's not just a set
it's sort of ordered what it's said and
and i mean presumably you could just do
that with you know yeah like the lambda
calculus or as a hack sort of encode the
states as a sort of binary
representation and and use something
like binary lambda calculus
not interpretable but it's it's the
problem is this the problem is how do
you make the connection with what humans
can understand
in other words being able to say which
branch in the multi-way system okay two
problems
in the multi-race system things are
being made dynamically so you don't get
to say
uh you know in other words you don't
know the structure of the multi-way
system until you've computed to that
stage in the multi-way system
and once you have the structure you can
absolutely say take the third fork in
this multi-way system but you don't know
in
in
you know at the beginning you don't even
know that there is a third fork
at this point you have to compute to
that point if you then say but and it
isn't an interesting strategy well the
strategy that we're taking in our
evaluator is essentially take the first
fork
in all in all cases just take the first
one
so i think that's combining things again
um
the like in the multi-way system the
nodes are whole trees
right
well
yes but i'm saying that you can do that
look a typical case would take the first
fork in the tree which is itself a
single node in a multi-way system and
that itself gives you a path in the
multi-way system but i don't think
that's like the first path that you see
i am indeed conflating this because i
mean it's it's like you evaluate
fibonacci
right and you've got like like for
example we can do that
in if we do
just to understand how this relates so
let's imagine that we have let's see can
we do this how does how do we do this
help me nick do you know how to do this
what am i going to do i'm doing a um i'm
trying to compute fibonacci using
i say if x
less than 2 1 otherwise
i want
help what am i doing here do i want a
list well nest graph doesn't have access
to
two steps before
right are you you can give me
that each step you have a list of two
things
this looks right stephen it's like
backwards yeah
do i do from like from this
three steps okay let me just no no but
this this is history
that's what i want right so this one
here i say vertex labels
this is
an optimized fibonacci
is that right right what am i doing here
i've got five well i thought nest graph
internally didn't assume determinism
unless that's been changed
i think it was changed
but
what am i even doing here what is this
doing this is
this is not an actual fibonacci i'm i'm
now confused about that
you know f six depends on f of five and
f of seven
okay so here i miss those numbers up
help what am i doing here
replace list five which is five
returned function
oh does this have to be a list here
oh yeah
okay what on earth am i seeing here
what are those zeros if you were gonna
compute fibonacci of five
then you would
naively do fibonacci of four plus
fibonacci of three okay so this is in
fact a fibonacci tree
is that true statement this is just the
downward
portion and then fibonacci is the
upwards portion
where you're actually
adding the results from each branch
okay
um
uh
well i see instead of list one do empty
lists
where here okay
oh that is is that a fibonacci tree now
yeah
but it's not doing a weird thing at the
end where it
keeps going
okay
but
so
okay so i mean the the challenge here
again is
is there a language and richard is
commenting on this don't care and and um
another primitive what was the other one
don't
i forget what the other one was but that
that's a possible way to represent
something they give an example uh
further down the paper um which is a
little chess game and they show
um how they sort of control the search
space exploration so that's kind of an
intuitive
example
section three not non-determinism in
elan
um
sorry i think you have the the wrong
paper the papers the non-deterministic
computations in the elan which was
i think the
the first link i sent in in the
uh it's actually the second link in the
chat the message which starts but on the
issue of evaluation strategy
okay okay
and then section three
uh non-determinism
and then
[Music]
okay so there are multiple things that
can happen
okay
well i mean in the paragraph just under
the chess boards this they say
um
yeah they get
yeah so there you go
yeah
yeah
this part i understand
the trouble is i mean that's saying very
locally what can happen
and that's like giving
the
replacement function in the multi-way
system
which
you know this is effectively defining a
multi-way system i think
this is not defining
a
this is defining the whole multi-way
system i believe
not defining in what order you will
sort of you know the the
does it doesn't the path that you take
in the multi-way system like if you if
we're thinking of having a strategy for
picking a path doesn't that strategy
depend on how you're representing states
as nodes
like strategies are going to be
described differently if you're
describing string rewriting or
expression rewriting
perhaps but i mean a strategy look at
some level a strategy it's like a proof
okay you can write out the path that you
follow in the multi-weight graph okay
the path in the multi-way graph is a
proof
if your strategy would be more like a
tactic
i think yes so tell us about how those
work how are those specified
so the
so tactics are is like a sketch in the
proof you just give indications of how
the
proof should proceed to a point that the
computer can fill in their gaps
right but how do you give those tactics
they're usually named tactics
yes you would say now use this big
theorem now use induction i'll use see
this is the thing this is what's driving
me crazy you know we got the same thing
all over the place we've got the same
thing in general relativity it's named
solutions the einstein equations
it's like it's not also when you compute
for instance
um we'll take
a grobner basis okay
which is like theory improving you're
gonna find the critical pairs and all of
that
but
that's what all the research has been
about
you know
the only thing you can give in
which is
too much freedom for most people
is variable orderings and there's way
more than n factorial possible variable
orderings right and that's what degree
lexicographic and all these kinds of
things come up yes
and they're they're sort of n factorial
lexicographic orderings but they're many
more orderings than that
right so but but inside it's using a
tactic like like jose describes
it's it's
it's
you know and those are the th
they're so sort of differently
efficiently
differently efficient ways of computing
the end result
and right and the the ordering matters
but there's also other stuff that you
can't control which is sort of the
implementation of the algorithm it's not
user
you know unless you implement it
okay but the basic point here the same
thing happens by the way in it in a
someway simpler context but they say
sparse
actually even denser linear equation
solving
so for neumann
and tur and turing and others you know
investigated the numerical stability of
gaussian elimination
right
you know and they found out that you
could deploy a tactic
which they call
pivoting
that would sort of you know
basically make it uh you know stable
right and
you know and right now
you know like our lu decomposition and
which is the norm in all of linear
algebras use what's called partial
pivoting which means you pivot the order
of equations but not the order variables
you know what's driving me crazy this is
the same problem i mean it's one of
these cases where the same problem is
just showing up in all these different
fields yeah and then if you go to the
next scale which is sort of sparse
linear equations
there's something called um
or orderings you know you you try to
reorder
the equations and variables
so that you minimize fill in because you
don't want to go from a sparse matrix
that's a million by million to one
that's dense that's like bad
and so there are things like cutie mcgee
or they're named you know because they
need to be cheap i knew it better cut
hill she was a charming person yeah okay
please go on
yeah there's a whole bunch named ones
you know and people have investigated if
you spend more time on trying to figure
out the strategy are you gonna win
and the sad result is that yeah no you
won't because you'll chew up too much
time trying to figure out the smart
strategy and you won't win
right
um
okay but but but
what we're learning from all these
examples the fact that every one of
these strategies has or tactics or
whatever has a name
means we haven't solved the turing
machine-like problem
perhaps when the space of possibilities
is so large and complex naming the
successful
ones is the only way to go
well yeah there's a similar thing of
picking variable orders for bdds for
boolean functions
they're n factorial possible ones you
can't okay so jose what would you say in
general relativity for example about um
you know
or even in special relativity about
reference frames they're again named
well in special relativity you can
parameterize them via lawrence
transformations but in general
relativity yes you name the
the gauge conditions to select
particular nice coordinates yes indeed
and is there anything beyond that i mean
that there are parameterized families
but that's about it
yes i mean there are so i mean the space
of foliations is absolutely infinite
right so yes you can slice space times
in some very many ways that
most of them are completely useless
so you just give you
yourself um
techniques to find them like harmonic
coordinates and things like that so
which are successfully
see see this is what old but see
here is what what i found that seemed to
be successful
in all these cases that i enumerated
and also for modern super scalar cpus
is to
is to basically adapt and do it sort of
locally and kind of real time so for
instance
for grabner basis what you can do
is that
you figure out how to reorder them as
you go as you learn more
i understand it's the same thing
automatically they're improving you
could imagine doing the same thing yeah
the same thing happens with basically
you know the way you figure out pivot
sequence is as you go you know you're
you've eliminated this far now what's
the pivot and you investigate your local
situation right there
right and the similar things there was
the breakthrough for bdds and that's
called um
it has a name but it allows you to sort
of reorder
kind of as you go okay but but just to
roll the clock back to 1936 for a second
imagine
you know we're talking about real
numbers
and people are saying oh we got all
these real numbers there are ones named
algebraic numbers and there are ones
named this and the ones named bat
and then
you know older he wasn't very old at the
time alan turing came along and said but
actually there's this class of real
numbers that are the computable reels
that are generated in this particular
way
that's kind of the type of problem that
we have right now
all we have you know in turing's time
all they probably had in the world of
real numbers was
named classes of real numbers
but there turned out to be a natural
class of real numbers that were
computable reals
so that's that's the challenge here what
is the natural class of these things
where people say i mean jose was just
saying you can have an infinite
collection of possible foliations many
of which have scrambled space-time into
some insanity that for example no
observer like us would ever deal with
yeah but but that particular case
you know in the
second half of the 1800s
you know with dirichlet and others we
did usually cuts and
cautious sequences there were at least
two models
of these infinite sequences
you know the real numbers yes
so those are not computable but they had
a way you know you could talk about them
right and we have a way we could talk
about i mean we have a variety of ways
we can talk about these foliations and
multi-wave paths and so on they're just
not very convenient
yeah dang there's got to be a solution
here i mean and the thing is what we
want is to be able to parametrize ones
that observers like us care about which
means they can't be unbelievably
complicated and you know and sort of
random they have to have some
irregularity and the question is how do
we capture just like computable numbers
and computability captures
something which is kind of somehow
accessible how do we capture that in the
same type of way
um
well at least we understand the problem
i just i don't know um
um
the uh
um okay there's just richard had another
set of comments and we should
unfortunately wrap up here about um
uh
um
the gpu uh
case yes i'll depends on synonyms yeah
actually it's a nice problem i'd
encountered and i was kind of
you know looking at
how could we
how could you incorporate these
techniques into a sort of more general
system so you know linear recurrences
have this data dependence between the
inputs and outputs
and so normally you would think that
such a problem is not paralyzable and so
these guys came up with this nice trick
where
based on the the signatures
you can sort of in parallel compute your
outputs with errors and then do a quick
fix up at the end so that that's the
idea of like a different
computation strategy which leads to
parallelism
where normally people would throw their
hands up and say it can't be done
um
and i kind of i keep yeah yeah keep
coming back to this example because i
think it's nice and also it's quite
practically
applicable you know linear recurrences
appear
all over the place okay so the claim
would be that normally a linear
recurrence if we look at the computation
graph for a minor occurrence it's going
to be a grid
is that right
quite it would be quite serial like a
sort of single chain of
operations especially if the signature
introduces
like i said the dependence between
um
a data dependence between your inputs
and and your outputs so that you can
sort of in parallel computer outputs
because you need to know the the
previous answer essentially
where did i get to where i'm at what did
i do wrong here
why is this
let's see with abc there
help me out somebody what did i do wrong
oh yeah yeah right
okay so
this is so what you're saying is and
it's sort of reminiscent of i don't know
fast fourier transforms or who knows
what else
your basic claim here is that there's a
way of reorganizing this computation
that does not involve so the the most
natural form of this computation would
be
to say at each step uh let's see what is
it is it a nest
help me somebody is is this a fold pair
list or something what is the
what is the operation that you're doing
the natural operation just with f of
whatever here
we say
it's the um
recurrence table
is that what i want what am i trying to
do a recurrence table
yeah right i guess that but but so what
you're saying is f of
n plus 2
equals equals
a times f of n plus y
plus 1 plus
b times f of n
actually i want it to be g of that or
something
maybe i'm just confusing myself here f
of n
and then i want to start with let's say
f of
five
and then what do i do for the here it's
part of the you have to give them in a
list kind of like for d solvendys all
that kind of thing what am i doing i'm
doing with f of five equals but why do i
do it why do i need to give up for five
explicitly
you need to give two initial values for
this to get going
f of five f of four maybe
or yeah
okay and then what do i do here i just
say f
or f of n
yeah
and then you have to say how many ends
you know what end from you know whatever
one to ten or something
and
what's that g doing oh well i was i was
trying to do something there that was
general function i see
i don't see why what's f actually f is
black is that something
oh gosh
well anyway but but
if i'm understanding what richard is
saying correctly
what he's saying is that there's a
potential
at the end yeah there's a essentially
there's a foliation which allows you to
get to the answer faster and if you
didn't know this technique you wouldn't
be able to to do so so i haven't read
your paper but we use a technique which
just basically divide and conquer so it
gets you an exponential speed up of
running these linear recurrences
is that what it is
i think not i think it's something
different here no it's like a kind of
mathematical trick or whatever so it's
like
you by introducing errors into your
output you get to this sort of halfway
point faster and then you do a quick
serial pass at the end which you can
compute very easily because it's just
the sort of generalized fibonacci series
so what you end up doing is introducing
errors in your output which are
computable or you know like
trivially computable
based on based on the signature of your
linear recurrence so it's yeah it's a
nice trick and it has some sort of like
practical utility
but but so i mean your point is that is
a
particular case
um
right it's
the the the question
being addressed is
if you allowed yourself to are there
computations where there is a faster
multi-way result
faster result on some multi-way path
or for example in in the case of the
superscalar processors
are you basically saying roger that a
superscalar processor is following
multiple bar
paths in the multi-way graph for a while
no but but it has
a backup it has a way of backing out
when it makes a mistake so the
performance
i thought they were doing multiple
actual instruction parts at the same
time they are they are but they they
sort of separate you know they're
different parts of the computation but
let's say you have a loop
and you need to predict whether you're
going to exit the loop or not
and what can happen is that you
mispredict and now you need to back out
a certain step
right and but the fact is that they're
very good at predicting that's why you
get such parallelism now
you know is like super good at
predicting compared to 10 15 years ago
right but
you're asking i mean
in um
what i thought was the case
and i thought that was the source of
some of these horrifying bugs
was that the cpu actually does do
it actually preemptively does multiple
evaluation chains
is that not the case that's actually
executing saying the result would be
this or this
if i were to go in this direction yes
and that's what they need to back out of
when it becomes clear that it wasn't
where it was going right but i mean the
the point of this is that cpus
are doing junior multi-way computation
maybe
yeah
they're doing uh they're doing local
multi-way computation
and so then this would be this this is
about kind of the bigger calculus
yeah richard you're right that's you
called speculative yeah yes speculative
execution exactly
um
and uh
right and i don't know how i mean i
don't know how many parts of speculative
execution they do but this is the same
same type of idea i think um
not much because um uh you're gonna lose
out very quickly
um
because it's
because they grow so so quickly so you
you you
the
um
what is that okay
it's interesting okay
multi-path yeah well okay so anyway i
gotta go because i've i'm super late for
some other
meeting here but this is okay guys well
i mean this is very i think this is very
interesting stuff but it's clear there's
a certain amount of heavy lifting
especially given that we're trying to
solve a problem that i at least have
been thinking about off and on for 40
years
um but it is also very interesting to
see that this problem is sort of a
convergence of
same questions that have come up in lots
of fields
i'm telling you there's an analogy
between
you know all these named strategies
i mean it is a little bit interesting
that turing machines
don't have a natural way to generate
algebraic numbers for example
in other words the branch of the named
numbers is separate from the branch of
the systematically generated numbers
for what it's worth
um
anyway i mean
okay last thought maybe from jose is
there anything you can imagine like any
constructive method for producing gauge
choices
you know aka foliations in general arts
holiday
or is it just you know write it down
so there are two different things one is
general coordinates that's that's like
choosing functions there's just too many
the second thing is the physically
useful
coordinate ones and then the ones that
observers would construct
and and and then there are named very
important ones like fermi coordinates
i think so that
yeah right but i mean and
okay but but i mean
right but that's the point we're we're
again
you know we're again at named coordinate
systems
the question is is there a systematic
way of constructing a coordinate system
like a turing machine like like a like a
a
you know an operational calculus of some
kind for generating coordinate systems
that's the question like imagine that
you were
building
a network of clocks
you know actually building it which
effectively amounts to constructing a
coordinate system
but if there is a physical process then
you can define the process
right and yeah just say i send the light
rays and and they go and come back and i
know
this type of thing right and yeah
exactly but i'm
i'm looking for something which is kind
of like a touring machine as in there's
this particular type of you know
constructor kit that you use to set up
your light ray you know it's like like
you've got an optical bench and you've
got various kinds of lenses and
splitters and this and that and the
other that you're using
and what are the natural
you know primitives that you might use
anyway i unfortunately have to go to a
different uh meeting about a very
different topic which i'm really late
for um
and uh well thanks everybody and uh i'm
yeah we we should we will we'll try to
sort of focus in a bit more carefully on
what it is where we're trying to move to
next but this has been it's very useful
and um
uh
thanks
until the next time and thanks to folks
on the live stream also